german economy minister robert habeck is
in israel today amid a looming energy
crisis habek is expected to discuss
potential ways to route israeli natural
gas to europe
israel has around 900 billion cubic
meters of proven gas reserves it
currently exports gas to jordan and
egypt which has its own lng ports to
ship the gas for example to europe but
so far only in small quantities
now israel is looking into ways to
export its natural gas directly to the
continent the east mediterranean
pipeline could connect gas reserves in
the levantine base into greece in
mainland europe via cyprus and crete
the eastmat pipeline can carry 9 to 12
billion cubic meters of natural gas
annually that's around 10 percent of
europe's supply but the project is still
in the planning stages for now and may
take years before it can be operational
and it's just one project among others
currently in exploration gina cohen
joins us now she is an expert on the
eastern mediterranean natural gas market
gina thank you for joining us now will
this project and
others like it will they be ready in
time will they be operational in time to
help europe's very current gas crisis
well
it depends exactly when we start
constructing them there are four
potential projects as you said um the
east med pipeline which would go all the
way from israel by cyprus into italy
and there's another shorter pipeline
which is potentially uh can be done to
go from israel to turkey
and then there are two liquefication
projects either using the egyptian
facilities or doing a floating
liquefication facility in israel each
one of these projects has a different
timeline
potentially the eastman pipeline project
to italy will be the longest lead item
take the longest to do
but all of them could be completed by
2027 which is the deadline by which
europe and the eu especially is hoping
to reduce its gas imports from from
russia
now that's quite a way away but what has
to happen in order to realize these
products these projects
well um on the israeli side which is
necessary
is to finish the feasibility studies of
all of them
the second thing on the israeli side is
the government here
has to take
certain regulatory
announcements and decisions for instance
on deciding on where the facilities
would be located and on the european
side what is important is for the
europeans
to decide strongly
that they are willing to buy long-term
gas supplies from a different source and
sign up to such contracts and not just
rest on their laws on talking and what
they're doing now and hoping that
renewables will be the um
the answer of all their problems
what sort of geopolitical challenges do
you see arising from these efforts to
bring gas from israel to from the region
even to europe
well the least challenging one
geopolitically is to build a independent
floating lng facility in israel
but
doing a pipeline to turkey has
geopolitical hurdles and that it would
be complicated at this time for israel
to invest billions of dollars and to put
all its eggs in the basket of bringing
gas to turkey because israel and turkey
have had very um difficult relations
over the last decade so from israel's
point of view this will be
complicated the eastman pipeline to to
to europe would be fined here
politically from israel but
this is one where turkey would object
because turkey is reneging on cyprus's
own um economic zones and
stating that certain areas belongs to
turkey and therefore turkey would object
so these two pipeline projects have
turkey as a geopolitical complicated
element in them thank you very much gina
cohen is an expert on the eastern
mediterranean natural gas market thanks
for your insights today
now the need to diversify away from
russian energy sources is coming
alongside measures to keep moscow from
using its oil money to finance its war
in ukraine but some economists say that
you use much touted oil embargo it does
not go far enough
sergey guryev joins us now from paris
welcome sergey
now you've said the embargo does more to
help moscow at least for now can you
elaborate
thank you very much
yes embargo is a game changer and
embargo which has been announced
by the european commission by the
european council first um
last week
is going to kick in half a year from now
which means before that time oil prices
will go up
in expectation that there'll be less oil
on the market uh and that means in the
next few months putin will actually get
more money rather than less money
because the oil will keep flowing
while the prices will be higher and in
that sense embargo is great but it will
work only half a year from now before
that
embargo is bringing more rather than
less cash into putin's coffers allowing
him to pay for soldiers to hire new
soldiers and in that sense more needs to
be done before the embargo kicks in
right but would prices spiking in the
short term really aid moscow so much by
most indications the war is on its way
to costing putin more than he can afford
that's correct um
we will see soon the data for may data
for april suggests that he's uh running
so far manageable but he's running a
budget deficit and in that sense yes
every additional
euro every additional dollar per barrel
comes into his coffers which allows him
to pay his soldiers now one important
issue here is that he doesn't announce
mass mobilization right a month ago a
lot of people would say putin will
introduce martial law declare a war uh
introduce mass mobilization he didn't do
that because that would be unpopular
instead
he hires soldiers he recruits soldiers
he pays them an order of magnitude more
than average wage so people can uh die
for him in ukraine most soldiers come
from poorer parts of russia and in that
sense even
a modest salary can actually attract
many soldiers even with that he's
running short recently he signed a law
that allows him to remove the uh the age
limit for recruiting soldiers so he
needs soldiers and he needs dollars to
pay the soldiers and in that sense of
course higher oil prices
support putin's war in ukraine
now as you say all those things have to
be financed but which measures do you
think should accompany the oil embargo
well um in my op-ed in project syndicate
i talk about two measures that's been
discussed by economists
in recent months oil tax and price cap
both would
reduce oil revenues putin's gigan from
exporting oil oil tariff or oil tax is
where
for each euro that
european consumers pay part of that
amount goes to a special escrow account
and sits there
later to pay for reparations russia will
have to pay to ukraine uh price cap is
something that mario draghi has argued
for and now european council is asked in
to ask the european commission to look
into
price cap for example for russian gas
means that european buyers would
agree to pay a limited uh amount for
russian gas and not more and further
more introduce
secondary sanctions against third-party
buyers who would love to pay more for
russian oil or gas and so this is
another measure both of these measures
would allow for
oil and gas from russia to keep flowing
but would limit would reduce drastically
the amount of money putin gets from
exporting oil and gas
economist sergey guryev thank you very
much
thank you